bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau trois théories
je voulais tout d'abord vous remercier
quant à l'accueil que vous avez fait à
la vidéo sur spider man 3 vous avez
vraiment kiffé et du coup bah voilà ça
me fait plaisir merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui on va parler de la partie
3-2 désenchanté sur netflix
il est possible que j'aie mi saison 3
dans titre mais c'est simplement pour le
référencement ne vous inquiétez pas
alors c'est une partie iii qui peut
sembler un petit peu moins palpitante
que les deux premières parties mais qui
va néanmoins être importante pour
notamment agrémenter et relier tous les
mystères entre eux sachez en tout cas qu
évidemment chaque théorie provient de
moi de mes pensées je te d'imaginer
moi-même évidemment et que
majoritairement bas au final les idées
vont suivre celle de la première vidéo
je vous avais fait sur désenchanté j'en
profite également pour finir pour vous
informer que vous êtes une très grosse
majorité à regarder les vidéos sans être
abonné à la chaîne n'hésitez pas à le
faire on théorise sur plein de sujets de
la pop culture qui risque de vous plaire
allez il est temps de balancer les
théories
dans la partie de désenchanter nous
apprenions que fut go n'était pas un
elfe qui a quitté son peuple par lâcheté
mais qu'au contraire c'est une
couverture pour sa véritable mission
confiée par le roi lui même trouvé le
secret des secrets nous en avions déjà
parlé dans le premier trois théories
dédié à désenchanter mais les
informations manquent est énormément et
par le biais de cette saison 3 il y a
moyen d'élucider certaines choses tout
d'abord il faut remettre les choses dans
leur contexte pour mieux définir
l'avenir elle food est une terre isolée
pour les elfes comme un royaume d'exil
nous savons que les elfes et est connu
entre guillemets dans le sens où il
avait déjà été aperçu par exemple
plusieurs siècles avant l'époque nous
suivons actuellement elle food n'est
donc pas le royaume d'origine des elfes
ils n'ont pas toujours vécu qu'au milieu
des bonbons des trucs mignon et c'est
tout ça c'est le comique du cliché on va
dire et on en a l'exemple avec le roi
des elfes qui est bien plus sombre que
ses semblables il ment à son peuple sur
le monde extérieur ils les isole même il
n'hésite pas à tuer d'autres elf si par
exemple quelqu'un a couché avec sa fille
il est dans le secret le complot avec
fut go et cherchent le pouvoir est
justement par rapport à ça leroy et
fugue au ont découvert que dream land
était le royaume originelle des elfes
par déduction cela veut dire que les
elfes ont été obligés de quitter le
royaume et au vu de l'inaccessibilité
del food se cacher mais qu'est ce qui
aurait obligé les elfes à s'exiler et
quitter le royaume d'origine qui leur
conférait un certain pouvoir
dans l'épisode 2 parties 3 de
désenchanter derek fait la découverte
d'un livre relatant l'histoire de la
famille de saugues et donc tous les rois
qui ont gouverné dreamland
il est dit apparemment qu'il existe une
certaine malédiction dans la famille
et que la fin de la lignée des héritiers
mâles la stoppe bref zaugg commençant
par un z
il est normalement le dernier roi maudit
avant que bin ne reprenne le pouvoir et
cassent cette fameuse malédiction et
dans le dernier épisode hautevalle et
big jo complotent par rapport à cette
dernière car la fin de la malédiction
est censée être l'aboutissement de leur
société secrète mais nous allons y
revenir plus tard le plus intéressant
est que big jo possède une des pages
manquantes relatant l'histoire de drogue
certainement le père deux ogres puisque
young était son frère
cette page contient des scripts qui une
fois analysée par oswald révèle qu' il y
a fort longtemps une bataille a eu lieu
entre les ancêtres de diaby ni l heure
et demie les ennemis de la famille ont
été vaincus et certainement par
vengeance ont lancé une malédiction sur
tous les héritiers au trône on ne sait
pas qui sont ces ennemis et on ne sait
pas quel est précisément cette
malédiction
mais si les ennemis étaient les selfs
comme démontré plus tôt leur histoire
correspond parfaitement à l'exil d'un
peuple suite à une lourde défaite
dreamland et en leur royaume d'origine
les ancêtres de diaby n'y aurait pris
contrôle du château et par vengeance la
malédiction des héritiers concorde avec
une prise du royaume pour le gouverner
je ne sais pas si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire exactement
d'ailleurs nous avons la venue des trocs
dans cette troisième partie dont le
symbole se trouvait sur la carte de
fugue haut et qui permettait de le
guider dans les catacombes
c'est rogge sont des sortes d'elf qui
vivent dans l'obscurité et on ne sait
pourquoi il considère bin el faux et
lucie comme leur sauveur mais des
sauveurs de quoi en fait
et si les drogues étaient des elfes qui
était resté caché après la défaite
contre les ancêtres de diaby n'y étant
banni en quelque sorte de leur royaume
il aurait survécu sous la terre et
l'obscurité ce qui a fait qu'il
ressemble à ça maintenant
surtout qu'ils ont une parfaite
connaissance du château et agissent dans
le plus grand des secrets
et vu que chaque peuple possède
légendes et ses prophéties leur sauveur
serait possiblement le peuple des elfes
qui souhaitent réveiller l'antique
pouvoir des elfes et reprendre leur
position
s'il ya bien un personnage qui est
difficile à cerner ses biens hautevalle
on ne sait pas à quoi il joue exactement
il souhaite tantôt la mort de drogue
mais s'inquiète pour lui par moment voir
le protège tantôt il a tenté de brûler
diaby ni à la fin de la saison 2 pour
prendre le pouvoir mais là sauf dans la
partie iii en lui dévoilant une grande
fidélité
bref il est incompréhensible et le
problème c'est que l'on ne sait rien
d'autre valent rien sur son passé en
quoi consiste exactement la société
secrète et je peux vous assurer que
toute cette méconnaissance ce n'est pas
du tout un hasard hautevalle s'est
énormément de choses et aj énormément
dans l'ombre
dreamland est composée d' idiots et je
me demande si ce n'est pas dû à la
malédiction de la lignée de saugues
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
contrairement aux autres audeval et
lucide prévoyant perspicace bref tout
linverse des gens qui composent le
peuple et seul un autre personnage
possède les mêmes qualités been
sauf que voilà bean est le personnage
principal est comme une sorte d lui qui
est censé raviver dreamland
donc si hautevalle est plus intelligent
que la moyenne c'est que son personnage
possède une importance qui n'a pas
encore été dévoilé et au vu de son
comportement et par rapport à la société
secrète je pense caudeval se la joue
perso on va dire il est à la fois un
ennemi est un allié
venons en aux faits la partie iii nous
dévoile que big jo est toujours vivant
et fait partie de la société secrète
il est donc un grand ali et d'autres
valent tous les deux sont très au fait
des légendes ou autre malédiction du
royaume notamment par rapport à la fin
de la ligne et deux ogres qui est censée
raviver dreamland dreamland qui comme
déclaré dans l'épisode de ce team landes
semble posséder un grand pouvoir magique
qui intéresse beaucoup alva pour voir
que semble posséder been étant le
symbole de cette renaissance du royaume
étant la dernière de la lignée est la
première femme mais pourquoi big jo ou
encore hautevalle souhaite l'apogée de
dreamland
et si grâce aux pouvoirs sommeillant de
dreamland audeval et big jo souhaiterait
raviver so do more on ne sait pas d'où
viennent réellement ces deux personnages
on ne connaît pas leurs origines
on peut juste suspecté caudeval était
aux côtés de dagmar avant qu'elle
n'épouse dog est justement au vu de
l'intelligence supérieure d'hôtes valve
ou encore big jo on comprend qu'ils ne
sont pas originaires de dreamland et par
rapport à un certain épisode on peut
suspecter certaines choses dont
l'épisode les limites de l'immortalité
big jo kidnappe helfaut et part à la
recherche du pendentif qui combinait
avec du sang d'elf permet de ramener des
gens transformer en pierre à la vie sauf
que big jo n'agit pas pour dreamland
puisqu'il est contre bin mais il n'agit
pas non plus pour marc os puisque la
famille de dagmar a envoyé un tueur pour
empêcher big jo de s'emparer du
pendentif donc pourquoi big jo souhaite
le pouvoir du pendentif
scénaristiquement big jo connaît toute
l'histoire de seaux d'eau mort comme si
il racontait l'histoire de son pays et
surtout vu qu'il fait partie de la
société secrète cela veut donc dire
caudeval est complice du projet donc
qu'obtenir le pendentif
quel faux était un but de la société
secrète il se pourrait donc que la
société secrète et pour but de faire
renaître leur royaume d'antan que maroua
lâchement dévasté en pactisant avec les
enfers la lignée maternelle de binh a
effectué un pacte avec les enfers afin
d'avoir le pouvoir de détruire so do
more la cité rivale qui empêchait
l'expansion économique de ma roue vu que
ma roue n'avait pas d'armé le pacte avec
les enfers leur a permis d'avoir des
pouvoirs magiques pour vaincre leurs
rivaux
nous savons que bin existe pour une
seule raison d'après dagmar rembourser
la dette de la famille avec les enfers
elle est l'élue de la ligne qui changera
les choses mais c'est là que c'est flou
en fait pourquoi been était l'élu et
comment rembourser cette dette
comme dévoilé par alva dans l'épisode de
ce team landes
dreamland possède de grands pouvoirs
magiques de par haute-vallée big jo nous
savons que la lignée deux ogres a été
maudite les empêchant très certainement
de pouvoir utiliser cette magie c'est
pourquoi bean est importante étant la
première héritière féminine been va
casser cette lignée de roy masculin et
lever la malédiction de la famille une
malédiction qui a fait que young le
frère de drogue a été tué par la société
secrète zaugg qui a failli périr face à
dagmar dans la première saison et je me
demande personnellement si ce dernier ne
va pas mourir dans la partie finale car
c'est le point clé dogues moeurs been
devient la véritable héritière élèves
donc la malédiction sur dream land
chaque royaume est proche de dreamland
pour une seule raison le grand pouvoir
qui sommeille dans le château elle est
là la dette
dagmar a épousé og pour devenir la reine
de dreamland et lui a fait un enfant qui
deviendra héritier au trône pour à la
fois lever la malédiction de la famille
deux orgues et réveiller le pouvoir
caché du royaume le but après était donc
d'empoisonner og pour accélérer le
processus sauf qu'évidemment been a
échangé les verts combine réveilla sa
mère après plusieurs péripéties
cette dernière lui dira de trouver la
magie mais pas quelque chose qui
sommeille au fond de bin non dagmar
parle de trouver quelque chose qui
symbolise la magie dans dream land maru
ayant emprunté des pouvoirs magiques aux
enfers pour détruire saut de mort le
passage au pouvoir de binh permettra de
réveiller le pouvoir secret de dreamland
et donc rembourser la magie emprunté aux
enfers vous voyez ce que je veux dire
néanmoins par rapport à la fin du
dernier épisode dagmar décrit been comme
la promise nous savons que bin possède
des pouvoirs
est-ce que c'est elle qui possédera la
magie de dreamland une fois la
malédiction levé ce qui expliquerait
pourquoi tous les grands noms souhaite
se marier avec elle comme elle va ou ce
qui semblerait être le dirigeant d en
faire le diable dans tous les cas tout
tourne autour de binh
elle est le point culminant de la série
et de toutes les intrigues et enfin
petit mot sur l faut je pense qu'il va
devenir le dirigeant des ogres puisque
comme dévoilé dans la saison 2 la reine
des ogres serait apparemment sa mère
s'ils viennent le chercher
ce n'est pas du tout un hasard merci à
tous d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu ici
et j'espère sincèrement que ça vous aura
plu
ces trois théories n'était pas forcément
énorme mais voilà désenchanté c'est
peut-être pas aussi être que que plein
d'autres sujets mais ça fait du bien de
changer de temps en temps et après une
première vidéo qui vous avez quand même
bien plus bas il fallait qu'on fasse la
suite quoi et et comptez sur moi pour
parler de la partie 4 qui sera
normalement certainement la fin enfin
voilà n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à me dire vos
idées vos théories en commentaire
évidemment je vous lirai comme toujours
et que le lionheart soit avec vous on se
retrouve très très vite dans une
prochaine vidéo
allez ciao
[Musique]